bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados qué tan lejos
estamos del primer gran conflicto
internacional por el acceso al agua
es un recurso imprescindible para la
supervivencia de todos los seres vivos y
al mismo tiempo el agua es un bien cada
vez más codiciado y escaso bien pues hoy
por hoy ya existe un conflicto latente
por el agua y es uno que podría llevar a
un enfrentamiento a gran escala veamos
de qué se trata esta es la gran represa
del renacimiento en etiopía un
megaproyecto que amenaza con detonar un
conflicto regional con egipto y sudán
por el dominio de las aguas del río
negro esta represa se proyecta como la
más grande del continente africano su
gigantesco embalse con una superficie de
casi 1.800 kilómetros cuadrados es más
grande que la ciudad de londres pero
porque su construcción genera tanto
revuelo a quienes perjudica y a quienes
favorecen y qué avances han tenido las
negociaciones entre estos tres países
empecemos por ubicarnos un poco este es
el lago tana lugar de nacimiento del
nilo azul que atraviesa a etiopía y que
aporta entre el 80 y el 85 por ciento de
las aguas al miro el nilo azul se une
con el nilo blanco en jartúm capital de
sudán estos son los dos afluentes
principales del nilo que desemboca en el
mediterráneo tras atravesar gente y es
aquí cerca de la frontera con ciudad
donde etiopía construye su represa un
proyecto que es orgullo nacional y con
el que el gobierno etíope asegura que
sacará al país de la pobreza tener un
motor para convertir la economía
principalmente agrícola e
industrializada actualmente menos de un
tercio de la población etíope tiene
acceso a electricidad y la presa
generaría 6 mil 450 megavatios de
energía eléctrica al año suficientes
para inyectar energía a toda etiopía y
además exportar una tercera parte de la
producción a los vecinos suena bien no
pues resulta que el sueño de unos es la
pesadilla de otros el principal
perjudicado de esta situación es egipto
ya que el país depende casi
completamente de las aguas del nilo que
provee el 96 por ciento del agua para
sus 100 millones de habitantes un punto
crucial en el debate es el tiempo en que
etiopía tome para llenar la represa
egipto pide que se haga de manera
gradual de tal manera que no afecte el
caudal del agua pero etiopía que alega
un derecho su verano quiere hacerlo
cuanto antes para poner en marcha tanto
la hidroeléctrica como sus ambiciones
económicas ya durante décadas etiopía
había propuesto hacer empresas en el
nilo azul pero egipto presionó para que
nunca lo hicieran no es por ello extraño
que la construcción de la gran represa
del renacimiento iniciará en 2011 en
plena primavera árabe y cuando egipto
vivía protestas masivas y estaba
distraído una eventual reducción en el
flujo de dichas aguas especialmente en
tiempos de sequía es visto como una
amenaza existencial por el cairo que ha
advertido de todo tipo de consecuencias
y es que según la onu egipto comenzará a
sufrir estrés hídrico desde 2025 en
otras palabras este conflicto implica
nada más y nada menos que el río más
largo del
y cuna de civilizaciones por miles de
años actualmente de más de 450 millones
de personas en 10 países dependen de sus
aguas para sudar la situación es
diferente aunque el país ha expresado
preocupación por la limitación del
caudal de agua que podría afectar
incluso a sus propias presas etiopía le
ha prometido que le vendería parte de la
energía producida a muy buen precio
además la represa regularía las
constantes inundaciones que padece sudan
actualmente la construcción ya está muy
avanzada e incluso en julio de 2021
las autoridades de etíopes iniciaron la
segunda fase de llenado una decisión
unilateral que crispó los nervios de
egipto y cómo van las negociaciones en
el centro del debate está que tanto
control tendrá un solo país etiopía
sobre el flujo de las aguas del nilo
egipto y ciudad insisten en la necesidad
de un acuerdo legalmente vinculante
sobre el uso de la represa del
renacimiento pero etiopía busca un pacto
que no sea una camisa de fuerza y cuyas
pautas puedan ser modificadas según su
conveniencia los diálogos han sido
auspiciados por la unión africana pero
sin mayores resultados en julio naciones
unidas propuso mediar entre las partes e
instó a mostrar una voluntad política
para llegar a un acuerdo pero etiopía se
niega a que la onu la unión europea y
eeuu medien en el conflicto dice que
sólo los países africanos lo pueden
hacer por considerar que se trata de una
cuestión meramente regional así las
cosas de la diplomacia y de la voluntad
política de estos tres países depende
que este gran conflicto por el agua del
nilo se pueda resolver por vías
pacíficas si les sirvió el vídeo para
entender el conflicto por el agua del
nilo vean más de este tipo en nuestras
redes sociales y los esperamos en otro
episodio de en 5 minutos aquí en france